[Music]
Merry Christmas and come back soon hey
boss you know the you Christmas baking
contest you're always talking about haha
the royal family of Belgravia invites
you to compete in our Christmas baking
competition can't believe it
[Music]
Christmas is a magical time of you I
just wish I had someone to spend it with
Christmas wishes have been known to come
true I am so sorry no problem
who are you Oh Lady Margaret delicate
Duchess a Montanaro Stacy denoble I
think we were destined to run into each
other I'm supposed to marry Prince
Edward on New Year's Day but I hate
being in the spotlight I want to get to
know what it's like to be a normal girl
I want to switch places with the on
switch places I've become you and you
become me get out will only be for two
days no one would even notice Stacy the
Novo how's it hanging
how's it hanging these matches it I
suppose it's the time if you say so
oh who you are Here I am I'm determined
to spend as much time together as we can
over the next few days anything I guess
I'm a bit nervous with the big contest
coming up
[Music]
all right keep a close eye on the
Duchess she seemed something different
oh uh terribly sorry that wasn't very
dignified it's all right
quite liked it actually Christmas should
be about that I've never seen you so
sentimental maybe you don't know me that
well I didn't think things would get so
complicated so what do we do
[Music]
I don't know if I can shoot this out
everything okay
yep I'm great
you
you